so subscription models why do they rock
and is there anything that people should
look out for
absolutely the rock because they offer
win-win situation
the lifetime value of the user is much
lower in one-time charge with
subscriptions will let users test before
the x and their trust enable us to
increase the lifetime value as an
entrepreneur you're facing two options
make create your own service or by a
third party service that offers the
ability to manage subscription models
strike braintree paper and others are
offering it to you
we recommend to go with the second
option because the first one we create a
lot of work that won't make your product
better
it's a classic reinventing the wheel
scenario you wish to avoid